so I'm almost in a sense redoing a story
from January of this year which is that
Kamala Harris is again being accused of
flip-flopping and backing away from
Medicare for all but this time I
actually don't think she is I think
there is a flip-flop here but it's a
different one from the one that most
people are talking about so let me set
this up for you we need to be really
clear about the terrible way in which
the health care questions were asked to
the Democratic primary candidates in
night one and night two of the debate
the main problem is the way that those
questions were framed was bound to lead
to confusion and I wish that candidates
had actually called out the framing of
those questions but I'll back up and
we'll get to that
back in January Kamala Harris did a CNN
Town Hall and during the CNN Town Hall
Town Hall she was asked about Medicare
for all and here's what she had to say
what is your solution to ensure that
people have access to quality health
care at an affordable price and does
that solution involve cutting insurance
companies as we know them out of the
equation I believe the solution and I'm
and I'm actually feel very strongly
about this is that we need to have
Medicare for all that's just the bottom
line
so that was very definitive but then the
day after that she backed off an advisor
of hers put out a statement saying well
she's open to more moderate ideas as
well like preserving D in the industry
we have in making tweaks to Obamacare
and it appeared to be a significant
backing off from Medicare for all so
then the debate happens late last week
and the day after Kamala Harris is
interviewed and once again the
accusations start flying that Kamala
Harris is flip-flopping that during the
debate she raised her hand and said I'm
for Medicare for all and that the day
after the debate she backed off of that
and said I'm not actually for Medicare
for all there is a flip-flop here but it
is not the one that is being reported
Kamala Harris said she was for Medicare
for all in the town hall in January the
next day she did sort of back off of it
and now she is again saying that she's
for Medicare for all the confusion is
again how that question was asked so net
let's now look and this is mostly visual
this is when the candidates were asked
raise your hand on healthcare
listen to how the question was framed
who here would abolish their private
health insurance in favor of a
government-run plan so Kamala Harris
raises her hand there and as I said at
the time this was a terrible terrible
question this led to confusion this led
to people being able to just cop out
claim they didn't understand it whatever
and case in point Kamala Harris was
interviewed on CBS the day after the
debate and she said oh yeah I raised my
hand but the question was would I give
up my private insurance for a government
plan not should I would I want private
insurance abolished and then she gets
into an argument with the interviewer
the interviewer says no no the question
was should private insurance be made
illegal and I called this question out
because it was improperly asked for
exactly this reason
and then Kamala Harris gives us I guess
what you would call her real position on
this issue at this point in time senator
another defining moment in the debate
was when every candidate was asked to
raise their hand if they would abolish
private insurance in that moment you
raised your hand but afterwards her
campaign says actually that's not your
position so what is your position on
private insurance so the question was
would you be willing to give up your
private insurance that's not how it was
such a plan and that's what you heard
right okay yeah that's certainly what I
heard and in terms of the AIIMS it's
supportive of Medicare for all and under
Medicare for all policy private
insurance would certainly exist and for
supplemental coverage but under Medicare
for all and my vision of it we would
actually extend benefits so for example
vision care dental care hearing aids
which currently are not covered and
anyone you know who's a senior can tell
you they're extremely expensive and
people have to come out of pocket to pay
for them included in my perspective on
the issue of private insurance is this
and I told the story last night look any
night in America there is some parent
who's got a child who has a fever that's
out of control and going to the
emergency room to get help in the middle
of the night
and then looking at those sliding glass
doors is there in their car in the
parking lot concerned that if they walk
through those sliding glass doors
they're gonna be out-of-pocket $5,000
because of the deductible they've got
insurance already out of pocket five
thousand dollars we're gonna have to
leave it there so you know 91 percent
and I'll just have 91 percent of the
doctors in America today are in Medicare
so you won't lose your doctor so I don't
actually see this as a flip-flop from
the debate in the way that I understood
the question but the whole point is the
question was terribly asked what did
they actually mean by the question were
they saying would you personally given
the option of giving up your private
insurance for a government plan opt for
that plan that was a reasonable way to
understand the question others
understood it to be the sort of
right-wing meme talking point of
democrats would make private insurance
illegal if such a government plan was
put forward and the question by virtue
of being a terrible question and
improperly asked led to exactly this
type of thing so I don't see the
flip-flop that some people are claiming
I don't see that Kamala raising her hand
means yes to Medicare for all and then
in the interview she said she's against
it
my interpretation of the Kamala
flip-flop is that in the town hall she
said I'm for Medicare for all and got
the political benefit of that the next
day a statement was put out in January
saying well she's open to other options
as well but she likes Medicare for all
and now apparently putting her finger to
the wind and recognizing that this is
not a good path forward if she is not
for Medicare for all look at how Joe
Biden is suffering as a result of his
position on health care she now again is
saying oh yeah I am just for Medicare
for all so bottom line it does seem that
Kamala Harris is on the Medicare for all
train right now but remember she can
very easily pay lip service to it and
say I'm in favor of it without having
any real plan or goal of implementing it
if she were to become president of the
United States
we need clarity from our elected
officials from the candidates in
particular about what their policy is
and you have done
dan is someone saying I'm for
medicare-for-all if you don't follow
that up and say okay if instead what was
proposed were simply some tweaks to
Obamacare would that be okay with you
unless you asked that follow-up it's
very easy to say I'm for Medicare for
all and I'm for the public option and
I'm for tweaking Obamacare and I'm for
also not really making too many changes
other than maybe expanding access to
Medicaid you've got to go further and
this is why the debate question fell so
so flat where now we're arguing about
which is the flop if there is one that
Kamala Harris made rather than a better
asked question during the debate would
have given us much more valuable
information about what these candidates
actually stand for if you love learning
new things you probably want to check
this out the David Pakman show today is
sponsored by Skillshare and we're giving
you two entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video